il est temps à présent de parler culture
pour cela nous retrouvons à sephora
namani bonsoir à ces forums soient flora
alors ce soir vous êtes nous présenter
raphaël pichon chef d'orchestre et chef
de choeur de l'ensemble pygmalion
également la programmation dans lequel
east il s'inscrit pardon pour les
spectacles de versailles oui tout à fait
à leur rappel bichon d'origine
versaillaise est l'un des plus jeunes
chefs d'orchestre français il a
seulement 31 ans il c'est très rare de
réussir à devenir chef d'orchestre avant
50 ans alors effectivement il ya
quelques années d'avant c'est un surdoué
de la musique qui a déjà réussi reçu par
dont un diapason d'or en 2008 lauréat
2014 du prix pour le chant choral de la
fondation bettencourt schueller et c'est
pas fini il a même gagné une victoire de
la musique en 2015
c'est ça on a tout dit alors il débute
la musique au sein de la maîtrise des
petits chanteurs de versailles puis
poursuit au sein du conservatoire
régional de versailles pour étudier le
chant le piano et le violent il part
ensuite au conservatoire national de
paris pour étudier la direction
d'orchestre il complète son cursus par
de la musicologie à la sorbonne
très jeune il a le rêve de créer son
propre ensemble et en 2006 ils forment
l'ensemble pygmalion avec 30 instruments
tisme et 30 instrumentistes et tout
autant de coeur cet ensemble travaille
principalement les répertoires baroque
classique et romantique avec des
instruments d'époque et depuis des
années il travaille tout
particulièrement les oeuvres de
jean-sébastien bach et jean philippe
rameau
alors cet ensemble a déjà parcouru les
plus grands opéras de france l'opéra de
bordeaux de versailles rouen à l'opéra
comique et à la philharmonie de paris et
participe également aux précise
prestigieux festival de musique à
l'étranger il a également était invitée
pour la saison 2015 2016 par laurent
bruner directeur des spectacles du
château de versailles
oui c'est ça invités pour trois temps
forts pour cette saison alors le premier
c'était en novembre dernier pour les
funérailles de louis xiv donné à la
chapelle royale dans le cadre du
tricentenaire de la mort de louis xiv
le deuxième temps fort vient d'avoir
lieu c'était ce week-end vendredi et
samedi 19 et 20 février à l'opéra royal
pour une re création sur scène d'orfeo
l'opéra de luigi rossi comme ils
diraient et c'est le premier opéra
représentée en france c'était en 1647
c'est là la recréation sur scène du
premier opéra français qui a été donné
alors non pas à versailles puisque ce
théâtre n'existait pas à cette époque là
mais aux tuileries dans une salle
d'opéra et des deux spectacles qui a
aujourd'hui disparu
nous étions en 747 louis xiii vient de
mourir louis xiv est encore tout jeune
et mazarin décide de faire venir en
france
cette nouveauté qu'est l'opéra qui vient
d'italie évidemment une oeuvre qu'on a
aujourd'hui oubliées qui restait comme
un événement très important de
l'histoire de la musique mais qu'on a un
peu oublié pour sa musique et qui
pourtant est un véritable chef-d'oeuvre
d'une puissance et d'une et d'une
sensibilité absolument incroyable alors
à l'époque c'était vraiment la
découverte pour le public français du
drame chanter des grands castrats
italien mais également des premières
machinerie qui permettait les
changements de décors et procurer une
illusion scénique inconnu jusqu alors
stress est très beau et prochain moment
fort pour cette saison au château de
versailles sera le 25 et le 26 mars à la
chapelle royale pour la passion selon
saint matthieu de jean sébastien bach
alors date particulièrement importante
déjà parce que la passion selon saint
matthieu c'est le sommet de l'oeuvre de
bach avec un grand dramatisme pour ce
compositeur qui n'a d'ailleurs il jamais
écrit d'opéra mais également je vous le
disais parce que bach a constitué pour
l'ensemble pygmalion un répertoire
auquel ils sont particulièrement
attachés il faut savoir qu'au début de
l'ensemble raphaël pichon formé le voeu
pour les 10 ans d'interpréter justement
la passion selon saint-matthieu donc un
moment fort en perspective c'est l'un
des plus grands chefs-d'oeuvre de jean
sébastien bach
celle aussi l'un des plus grandiloquents
en l'un des plus ambitieux aussi en
termes de taille puisque il y a deux
orchestres 2 que qui dialoguent l'un
avec l'autre et qui permettent d'avoir
une grande vivacité dans la narration de
cette histoire que tout le monde connaît
qui est celle de la passion du christ et
et qui est une histoire aussi avant tout
très humaine qui exprime énormément de
sentiments très contrastées et une
musique d'une puissance absolue
ce sera donc une première pour raphaël
pichon et son ensemble nous n'avions
donc pas d'extrait à vous montrer mais
nous sommes quand même allés chercher un
extrait de l'ensemble pygmalion jouons
du bac ray que pour le plaisir
et
oh
ce sera donc le 25 et 26 mars prochains
la chapelle royale du château de
versailles merci beaucoup à sephora